好的各位同学
我们又见面了
在听过三一堂课之后
只觉得歌词创作班的CP值很高
内容很多元更丰富
那这堂跟大家分享的是
歌词是社会的共同记忆
怎么说呢
因为歌词借由音乐的辅助
再加上歌手的演绎跟传唱
他有了一个听觉上的一个生命力
而这个生命力是无限的延伸
虽然歌词的文字结晶度
跟他遣词用语里面的叙事的一个丰富性
没有诗歌来的强
但请记住多数的状况下
这其中有很出类拔萃的作品
像鲍勃迪伦
2016年诺贝尔文学奖的得主
他就是流行音乐的创作者
他得奖的理由是
他用诗意创造了一个世界
早就超越了所有的可能性跟范围
而他获奖的作品正是歌词
这个是不是给大家一个很重大的鼓励呢
也就是说歌词的可能性是无远佛界的
怎么说呢
一首好的歌词怎么判断旋律
把它抽走之后
歌词本身还具备阅读的文字张力
跟再次咀嚼的一个品味空间
那就是一首好的歌词
像我有一些中国风的作品
它里面的一些用语
它是呃仿古诗词的韵味去创作的
正因为我是仿古诗词的韵味去创作的
所以里面的文字结构跟他的一个文字的空间
跟想象比一般白话去叙述的歌词来得有韵味
来的深刻
譬如我青花瓷里面有所谓的散热
言外芭蕉惹骤雨
门环惹铜绿
而我路过那江南小镇惹了你
然后烟花易人里面呢也有所谓的三等
容我再等历史转身
等酒香醇
等你弹一曲古筝
还有红尘客栈里面的山
如我说缘分一如参禅
不说话
我泪如梨花
洒满了纸上的天下
爱恨如写意山水画
还有兰亭序里面的三院
又怎么会心事密缝
绣花鞋
针针怨怼
若花怨蝶
你会怨着谁
像这样子对仗的一个譬喻法
也只有汉字才能拥有
因为汉字是单音节的孤立语
所以我的中国风创作里面
才可以创出所谓的三惹三等
三如跟三怨
这是汉字特殊的一个文字结构
让我们作词者在更换词句的时候
有一个立即性跟一个无限的可能性
创作其实来自于生活的观察
同学们想要学习好歌词创作
你不能只看别人的歌词作品
纵使我当初要进入这个唱片公司的时候
那时候我住桃园
那时候我是怎么练习歌词创作的呢
我把很多老师的歌词结构去分析
因为市面上基本上没有人在教歌词创作
你可能可以教到人家弹keyboard答案
下个是风弹钢琴
然后甚至横笛洞箫都有一些课程在函授
但是你说扎扎实实一堂歌词的课程
按部就班去分析
去研究
去授课
我那个年代没有
但是这个年代有了
就是这一堂歌词创作班
各位同学很幸运的
圣盾的年代
我们拥有的歌词创作班
喜欢歌词创作
你不能只研究歌词
就像我当初我不是只有研究歌词而已
我涉猎了很多领域的一个著作
那这些著作都会变成你创作的养分
譬如我可能看蒋勋讲美学的书
甚至席慕容的诗
他会打动你的心
它会让你的视野更加地辽阔
举例来讲
上一堂课
不是讲到阅读是投资报酬率最高的事情
怎么理解呢
你看这个人的著作
再看着这个人的说法
还有那个人的观点
你自己独立客观地刑诉意见才会慢慢地清
你see阅读虽然是投资报酬率最高的事情
但是你绝对不能只看某一类别的著作
某一个人的书籍
那你的观点
你的视野
你的论述就会受这个人的影响
所以各位同学
我一直强调
想要写好歌词
你一定要关注日常的生活讯息
你一定要学会用观察的画面感
去把文字表达出来
那话题再回到刚刚中文的一个特殊性
也就是所谓的单音节孤立语
这个带给我创作上的一个方便
因为我会换一个介词
我只要换一个字就好了
甚至我写了一首歌词
我举例来讲
可能像你是否能够不要离开我
你是否能不要离开我
你是否能不离开我
很方便
你只要抽换单字或一个词语
那意识的完整性并没有被破坏
只是可能稍微不那么细腻了
然后稍微平铺直竖了点
稍微这么的直接
但是更换词句是汉字的一个优势
我们就是一个字一个音
所以更换词句对于歌词创作来讲是很便利性的
再就是说我虽然在从事歌词的创作
但是因为歌词创作的风格
来自于这个人的价值观
是因为我很喜欢中华的传统文化
所以才有所谓的中国风歌词
这个中国风歌词不是一夕之间有这个想法的
是你本来就在这样子的思维
这样子的价值观里面成长
所以你吸收触类旁通的一些色略
都跟这个领域有关
那你会发现说这个世界很美好很大
任何事物都可以被列为学习的目标
举例来讲
我最喜欢的汉字
就跟大家分享课堂以外的一个学习心得
你们知道吗
汉字是这个地表上唯一还在使用的表意文字
其他世界各国全部都是拼音文字
你说中东和北非的阿拉伯文是拼音文字
斯拉夫民族
俄罗斯用的基里尔字母也是拼音文字
那全世界最大范围内使用的拉丁字母
也是拼音文字
甚至于像印度
印度的天城文
他钞票上的那个文字也是拼音文字
日本的片假名也是取汉字的
楷书的偏旁变成片假名
然后取草书的结构变成平假名
所以所谓的假名嘛
那这些文字的一个借用
其实是每个民族都会互相的学习
但是汉字很特别的是汉字的字形
字意千古不变
汉字是超时空超低超方言的一种文字
今天在这里跟大家分享这样子的一个
我长期以来的观察
你的作品才能深刻
那怎么说汉字是超时空超低超方言呢
举例来讲
汉字因为不是拼音文字
所以日本继续用的山就是山
水就是水
韩国早期也借用了
虽然他们现在有自己的谚文
有自己的字母
但是你去韩国那种古迹
名胜古迹
你去看
你会很惊讶地发现
他所有的名胜古迹里面的牌匾对联都是汉字
因为他在500年前基本上还是汉字在运作
像越南也是当初也是借用汉字
是作为一个法定的通行文字
所以呢你去越南的名胜古迹
看到的结果跟韩国一样
他们19世纪以前的主要文字是汉字
那变成说我们对他们来讲是别的民族
但是呢我却可以直接看懂你们老祖宗的文字
他们的下一代反而不能阅读
因为越南被法国统治过
像现在越南通行的文字系统
是用法语的字母去拼的
所以你去越南观光旅游看到诶
怎么好像英文其实不是你读不出来
因为文字的排列不一样嘛
所以这个是很耐人寻味的
就是说汉字它的一个独特性
它被别的民族借去用了
他的字形之意不会改变
甚至他是穿越时空的一个文字
怎么讲呢
我们用历史的经纬度去设一个年代
比如说可能2000年好了
2000年大概是汉初汉朝的初年嘛
汉朝流行的文字系统叫隶书
汉隶隶书
我们现代人可以直接读懂隶书
它不是篆
不是秦篆
秦朝的时候那种小篆篆
就是印章
印章上面的那个你看不太懂的文字
那个是文字变化里面的一个系统
那我们就用西元2000年
来做一个时间轴的经纬度
假设有一块石碑
2000年前的石碑出土在埃及
现在埃及人绝大多数都看不懂
因为2000年前的石碑是埃及的圣书体
对他们来讲已经已经是古文字了
现在埃及通行的文字是阿拉伯文
这块石碑一样出炉
在墨西哥
2000年前是玛雅文化
全墨系个人都看不懂
因为玛雅文化基本上被破译的百分比不高
他留下来的文字线索很低
玛雅文化很特别
有点像漫画的那个结构
你现在如果有兴趣
百度上去打玛雅文字
你会发现玛雅文字很可爱
因为像漫画漫画的语出胖胖的一整块的文字
现在的墨西哥是拉丁民族
他怎么可能看得懂玛雅文化
玛雅文化遗留下的遗产
他不能继承
也不能使用好
这个石碑
如果出土在中东两河流域
叙利亚
叙利亚人一样看不懂
叙利亚整个是中东阿拉伯文的一个流行的范围
他们也看不懂
但是这个石碑如果出土在中国的西安
也就是以前的长安
我告诉你一个惊人的事实
我们的高中生可以直接看懂碑文
这是全世界范围内所有民族都做不到的事情
因为2000年前有一个成熟的文字系统
可以被使用
可以被继承知识的一个沉船跟文化的延续
基本上2000年前
很多民族根本文字的萌芽都还没开始
文字的建构都还没有很成熟
所以呢2000前的慈悲出处在现在的西安
我们应该是初中生都看得懂
因为他是隶书体
蔡北斋是文言文的隶书体
大概的意思看得懂
你要更细读
给它翻译成白话文
这个就是中文的魅力一样的石碑
出土在各个文明古国
包括印度
现在印度文也是拼音文字
2000年前的印度
所通行的字母系统叫做婆罗米文
现在印度钞票上的字母叫天成文
文字系统是不一样的
基本上有点像篆书跟楷书
就是你同民族的人如果有去学习
他还是可以看得懂
但是一般人没有去涉猎
没有去钻研
他是看不懂的
就像我们大多数的人不能直接读懂篆科一样
但你自己的名字
简单的笔画你是看得懂
但是整篇都是钻科的文章
现代人大多数整篇文章我们是看不懂
但是个别的印章你是看得懂的
你只有你的名字嘛
它带有符号性跟神秘感
所以很多书画家落款的时候
还是喜欢用篆刻的印章
因为他有个线条
带个符号
信他有个仪式感
他喜欢盖篆刻的印章
而不是楷书
也不是行书
这个告诉我们说
生活上到处都有学问
到处都有文化
你只要关注这个领域
你就会发现别人看不到的世界
你就会了解别人未能探索的区域
这个对创作来讲是非常有意义的
怎么讲
我刚刚讲中国的文字是超时空超低超方言
那有些人说这个跟作词有什么关系
当然有关系啊
我之所以创作这么多
所谓中国风的一个歌词的类型
就是来自于我关注这样子的传统文化
这样子的传统化变成我的气质
变成我的风格
所以显现在作品上
他就有自己的识别度
这个识别度对于创作者而言很重要
歌词创作很重要的一环是
你的作品需要具备个人的创作识别度
因为像品牌一样
就好像有些摄影师他可能很擅长反差的光
有些摄影师可能是粗粒子的纪录片
那有些摄影师可能很钻研光晕的一个变化
他可能等了很久
就等一个自然光都有可能
那这个就是你个人的品牌
你个人的创作识别度
创作一定要具备显而易见
旗帜鲜明的一个个人识别度
这个个人识别度无形中就代表你的品牌
这样子的好处是说
因为这个社会太竞争了
太激烈了
你一定要有个独树一格的作品识别度
你才能具备不可被取代性
不可被取代性是什么意思
今天流行音乐的歌词领域
你少了谁有什么差别吗
创作的人才济济
竞争这么激烈
那为什么非要你站在这个位置呢
哦原来你的存在丰富了歌词创作的领域跟类别
就譬如说我创作了一些中国风的一些代表作
其实我写了大概四五百首歌
但是被人家熟知的
就是那些所谓比较经典的中国风创作
因为他的类别很鲜明
因为他的风格很明确
大家因为这样子的明确跟风格而认识了你
而记住了你
那你在这个圈子就具备了不可被取代性
你就拥有了这个领域的话语权
这是非常重要的
所以呢学习创作
触类旁通跟学习是非常重要的
而不是说哦我在学习歌词创作
我我只focus在所有人的歌词创作
我的目光不会移到别的地方去
这样子的创作会会有狭隘
会僵化
因为你的眼界看不到别的地方
等于是你的作品没有景深
这是很危险的
所以各位同学很重要的一点
我们虽然这堂课是在教歌词创作班
但是你要有个心态学习这个东西
一定要跨领域
跨的领域越多
你个人的一个主观意识越容易形成客观的创作
那你的东西就有一个所谓的作品识别度
你就会变成一个品牌
这个是创作上来讲非常至关重要的事情
跨界的去吸收
最终你才能摸索出行
做出自己独
固有的风格
我们回到刚刚的议题
歌词如何是一个社会的共同记忆呢
因为音乐是情感的催化剂
歌词它并不是单独的存在
但必须与音乐结合
才有完整的生命
再加上歌手的演唱跟散播
让这样子的一个听觉进入了你的生活周遭
进入了你的情感
变成说歌词能办得到的
诗歌办不到
还有一点很重要
所有的情感交流跟分享
绝大多数的时候
只有歌词或者是所谓的流行音乐才能办得到
举例来讲
你肯跟同学跟朋友
跟同事跟同财间一起相约去看某一个乐团
某一个歌手的演唱会
那将是你青春时期一段美好的回忆
因为情感可以交流
因为开心可以分享
而这些鲜活的情感交流跟细腻的情感催化
就不是纯粹的文字作品
也就是诗歌所能超越所能影响
所以歌词它具备了情感的共同记忆
举例来讲
很像很早期崔健的一无所有
或是罗大佑的鹿港小镇
我相信这些歌活在某一些人的青春
某一些人的生命里
某一些人的记忆里
再像老狼的同桌的你
或是说周传雄的黄昏
林忆莲的
至少还有你这些歌
只要某一个青春岁月
某一个时光
你跟朋友一起听
一起听的
当下你就在刑诉你的人生的
共同记忆
所以音乐借由听觉
借由视觉
借由演唱会的交流
他定格了你的人生记忆的某一个区块
它变成你人生剧场的荧幕风景
是你生活记忆的一块拼图
搞不好哪一个歌手的哪一首歌就是你的青春
这样子的一个渗透性
跟歌词的一种情感的交流与催化
就不是纯粹的文学作品所能取代
所以各位同学记得歌词的价值在这里